[Musique]
et
napoléon bonaparte était un génie
stratégique politique et administratif
l'un des plus grands chefs militaires
que le monde ait connu il exploita de
nationalisme naissant de la france
révolutionnaire pour bâtir le plus grand
empire d'europe depuis les romains
victor hugo lui-même disait que c'était
à prométhée
c'est un homme extrêmement intelligent
qui se voulait pour lutter contre
l'extrême sensibilité de sa pensée il se
voulait très rationnel
son énergie hors du commun son
intelligence supérieure et son esprit
rebelle lui permirent de conduire sa
nation d'adoption vers une gloire sans
précédent une fois sa puissance établie
napoléon se construisit un personnage
sur le modèle de césar
l'homme d'état général romain de ce fait
il fut considéré à la fois comme un
libérateur est un tyran comme un héros
et un criminel c'est un homme qui croit
en son étoile et qui fait tout pour
aller dans ce sens
c'est un homme qui ne se posent pas de
questions qui n'a pas de cas de
conscience
donc c'est un homme qui se laisse aller
à ses instincts d'une certaine façon son
désir de puissance et sa détermination
sans faille le porter en triomphe puis
ça la défaite
premier d'entre les dictateurs moderne
il eu une importance et une influence
incontestable par son ascension
fulgurante vers le pouvoir
il était déjà une légende à son époque
et reste très présent dans l'inconscient
collectif des français napoléon fut donc
une personnalité extraordinaire qui
vécut à une époque également
extraordinaire et su saisir
l'opportunité qui s'offrait à lui est il
qu'on quitte ainsi l'europe domine à son
siècle et changer le monde
imaginons nous qu'en 25 ans de temps ce
garçon qui avait traversé l'histoire
comme une météore en 25 ans de temps il
avait bouleversé le robe beaucoup plus
qu'elle ne l'avait été en qu'un siècle
encore aujourd'hui et c'est bien aussi
sans génie les historiens beaucoup de
mal à faire la différence entre le mythe
et l'homme napoléon lui-même
évoquant ses mots cette confusion dans
son mémorial de sainte-hélène
il faut en convenir les véritables
vérité sont bien difficiles à obtenir
pour l'histoire heureusement que la
plupart du temps sont bien plutôt un
objet de curiosité que de réelle
importance
une fable convenu
la révolution française éclate en 1789
quand le peuple se soulève contre
l'ancien régime
le roi louis saez tente désespérément de
réformer le mode de gouvernement
en devenant un monarque constitutionnel
et de freiner le mouvement
révolutionnaire mais la convention élu
au suffrage universel aboli la monarchie
et instaure une république qui doit
donner une nouvelle constitution à la
france le jeune bonaparte à l'époque
lorsqu'il découvre les prémices de la
révolution il doit se dire parce que il
le confiera par la suite que dans la
rome républicaine on faisait toujours
appel un dictateur lorsque le désordre
était à son paroxysme et il se dit sans
doute que pour des gens comme lui c'est
dire des hommes d'ordre et d'autorité de
cette révolution pourra naître chez lui
une ambition
au début les autres puissances
européennes se contente d'observer les
conflits internes qui agite la france
les après le régicide de louis saez
souverain bourbon l'ombre inquiétant de
la révolution française plane sur le
pouvoir des rois de tout le continent
les intérêts nationaux s'affrontent
favorisant l'extension des conflits
le déclin du féodalisme et l'exécution
de centaines de généraux sous le régime
de la terreur offre la possibilité un
homme talentueux de se faire une place
de choix dans la hiérarchie militaire
c'est à ce moment précis que ce jeune
homme issu d'une famille modeste saisi
sa chance
nul ne se doute alors qu'il atteindra de
manière fulgurante les sommets du
pouvoir
son nom résonne encore dans l'histoire
napoléon bonaparte fils d'un avocat
appartenant à la noblesse de robe corse
voilà parts entre dans l'armée française
en 1785 en tant que lieutenant
d'artillerie en 2d lorsque la révolution
éclate bonaparte n'a que 19 ans mais il
se fait très vite connaître à l'occasion
de la reprise de toulon aux royalistes
la stratégie militaire de napoléon se
révèle aussi tôt à toulon en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui a le coup d'oeil
il a immédiatement le coup d'oeil il est
capable de se transformer des plans sur
le champ de bataille c'est ce qu'il fera
à wagram en 1809 en particulier mais on
a déjà le cas à toulon bonaparte connaît
une ascension rapide car il est soutenu
par robespierre
ce qui lui vaudra d'être brièvement
arrêtée en 1794
lors de la chute de ce dernier il a été
l'homme de robespierre leuven et c'était
quelqu'un qui était proche des
dirigeants de la terreur et donc il a
été associé à ce mouvement puis après
c'est très dur quand il a rêvé la
réaction thermidorienne c'est à dire qui
il est poursuivi il est arrêté il fait
quelque temps en prison
et puis après lorsqu'il est
désoeuvrés sur le pavé de paris il
abandonne sa sa petite fiancée désirée
clary à marseille et puis les seuils de
de se mêler aux mondanités de la
capitale et c'est très très dur parce
que hélas son accent corse il est pauvre
il a des titres de gloire militaire mais
qui sont pas grand chose dans cette
société du directoire à 27 ans il se
voit confier le commandement de l'armée
française d'italie au cours d'une
brillante campagne de 18 mois il bat les
autrichiens et l'italie revient sous le
contrôle de la france
convaincu d'être promis à un destin
extraordinaire
le jeune homme étant rapidement son
ambition au delà du champ de bataille à
l'arène politique il se projette à
l'échelle mondiale la colonisation par
la grande bretagne de l'inde de
l'australie et de certaines îles
d'intérêt stratégique a permis aux
britanniques de bâtir un empire global
appuyé sur sa puissance maritime son
activité commerciale et industrielle
font alors de l'angleterre la nation la
plus riche de son temps pour bonaparte
l'egypte est la clé de la puissance
mondiale sa conquête donnerait à la
france l' avantage d'arriver plus vite
en inde que ses concurrents et de
menacer les colonies britanniques si
rentable
[Musique]
à
mais l'expédition est mal organisé
munitions et provisions n'arrive pas à
temps et la force maritime des anglais a
été sous-estimé bonaparte et ton plat
combat contre les mamelouks d'égypte
canton amiral anglais lors de nelson
découvre la flotte française amarrés
dans la baie d'aboukir lorsque le
brouillard des canons se dissipe
il ne reste plus que deux navires
français sur les 17 qui mouillait là il
se sent un petit peu pris de panique si
bien qu' il va déléguer tous les
pouvoirs à kléber en egypte et il va
partir mais véritablement presque comme
un malpropre c'est à dire discrètement
il va traverser la méditerranée
au risque de se faire et prôné par par
la flotte par britannique et il rejoint
la corse et de là il rejoint la france
abandonnant un peu quand même
son arme et en egypte
[Musique]
il n'a pas atteint l'inde
mais le caractère romantique de cette
aventure suffit à lui apporter le
prestige et la gloire
on ignore en france les crimes de guerre
perpétrés en egypte et en syrie par
napoléon bonaparte l'armée qui l'a
abandonné sur place ne rentrera que deux
ans plus tard
cela lui laisse amplement le temps de
travailler à ses ambitions en glorifiant
sa campagne d'égypte la guerre reprend à
travers toute l'europe se met en place
contre la république française qui est
celle du directoire à l'époque une
seconde coalition qui réunit à la fois
les russes les autrichiens les anglais
naturellement qu'ils sont toujours dans
l'ombre et qui paye l'europe d'ailleurs
pour faire la guerre à la france
la révolution française a accompli son
rôle historique
elle a aboli les privilèges de classe et
accorder la souveraineté au peuple en
misant sur le fait que la constitution
et les hommes politiques se perfectionne
ray avec le temps mais dix ans ont passé
et la france est encore au proie aux
luttes révolutionnaires temps sont cinq
à l'étranger
les royalistes s'agite et les
républicains les plus extrémistes à dire
les nostalgiques de la terreur justement
également reprennent du poil de la bête
si j'ose dire
et donc c'est dans ce contexte que
bonaparte va revenir d'egypte et un mois
après il va faire son coup d'état qui va
mettre bas le directoire est donc grâce
à ses talents de militaire il va
aussitôt redresser la situation
le très impopulaire directoire est
remplacé par le consulat conçu sur le
modèle de la république romaine le
pouvoir exécutif est confiée à trois
consuls élus bonaparte se sert de son
immense popularité de sa gloire
militaire pour assurer son élection au
titre de premier consul il devient alors
le personnage le plus puissant de france
il affiche rapidement son intention d'
étouffer les guerres fratricides afin de
rétablir la paix dans ce but il
s'entoure de deux consuls aux
sensibilités différentes cambacérès et
le bras cambacérès régicide grand
spécialiste du droit est un ancien
député de la convention ministre de la
justice sous le directoire lebrun
spécialiste des finances est quant à lui
partisan d'une monarchie modéré
installée aux tuileries dans l'ancien
palais royal
bon à part te met en place un
gouvernement autoritaire sous des
apparences démocratiques ayant assisté à
la violence du siège des tuileries en
1792 il craint la fureur populaire et
croient dans l'ordre social
la constitution de l'an huit organisées
verrouille le pouvoir législatif divisé
en trois assemblées
le tribunal qui discutent les loi
préparé par le conseil d'état le corps
législatif qui les adoptent où les
rejette et le sénat conservateur qui
vérifie si la loi est conforme à la
constitution
le premier consul se réservant le droit
de corriger les résultats qu'ils ne
considèrent pas satisfaisant quelques
intellectuels avaient prédit à juste
titre que la révolution finirait en
dictature ou chateaubriand monsieur de
chateaubriand qui a été d'abord un
admirateur forcené puis voyant que le
l'ambition de l'empereur était de plus
en plus effréné sans borne sans limite
eh bien il a commencé à mettre un petit
peu de l'eau dans son vin pour finir
même pas par ne plus apprécié du tout
napoléon 1er
dix ans de rébellion de coups d'état et
de répression entraîner chez la
population un désir profond de paix et
de sécurité
cela mène la france à sacrifie la
liberté la démocratie qu'elle a connu un
court instant dans le but de retrouver
la stabilité et un homme à poigne qui
tiennent fermement les rênes du
gouvernement
[Musique]
si le consulat mais en terme à la
révolution
les conflits se poursuivre sur le
continent une deuxième coalition se
forme contre la france l'autriche et la
russie soutenue par la grande bretagne
lève de nouvelle armée pour mener des
campagnes en allemagne et en italie
bonaparte propose alors directement la
paix au roi de grande bretagne et à
l'empereur d'allemagne
la guerre qui depuis huit ans ravage les
quatre parties du monde
doit-elle être éternel n'est-il aucun
moyen de s'entendre
comment les deux nations les plus
éclairés de l'europe puissante est forte
plus que ne l'exigent leur sûreté et
leur indépendance
peut-elle sacrifier à des idées de vingt
grandes heures le bien du commerce la
prospérité intérieur le bonheur des
familles comme on ne sont elles pas que
la paix le premier des besoins comme la
première des gloires extrait de la
lettre de bonaparte au roi d'angleterre
la grande-bretagne balaye d'un revers de
main cette proposition de paix en
exigeant le rétablissement de la maison
de bourbon ainsi que le retour du
territoire français à ses anciennes
frontières
[Musique]
précipitée dans une nouvelle impasse les
deux géants doivent alors se préparer à
un autre conflit sanglant alors
bonaparte d'abord à un travail
absolument énorme à remplir en 1800
lorsqu'il prend le pouvoir
d'abord il faut sauver la france de
l'invasion donc il va réorganiser une
armée de 40 mille hommes en prélevant
des troupes un peu partout en france
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'armée de
réserve qui traversera les alpes au
grand saint bernard et keira remporté la
victoire sur les autrichiens donc à la
bataille de marengo le 14 juin 1800
l'armée autrichienne conduite par le
général von mélasse envahi l'italie
espérant frapper la france par le sud
afin de vaincre les troupes
autrichiennes bonaparte élabore une
stratégie audacieuse et spectaculaires
dont lui seul détient le secret alors
que le général masséna est bloqué avec
30000 hommes dans la ville de gênes
assiégée par 90 mille soldats
autrichiens votent mais là ce ne voient
pas le danger imminent que l'armée de
réserve
conduite par bonaparte fait peser sur
l'arrière de six troupes comme
charlemagne et hannibal avant lui
bonaparte conduit son armée à travers
les alpes et passe le col du grand saint
bernard à la frontière franco italienne
avec quarante mille hommes et une
centaine de cas dans le 9 juin 1800
l'armée française commandée par le
maréchal lannes offre au premier consul
une première victoire à montebello après
11 heures de combats acharnés
bona park uni ses forces à celles du
général masséna et se déplace vers le
sud pour affronter la principale arme
est autrichienne le 14 juin 1800 aura
lieu la grande bataille de marengo
mais la veille de la partie le plus
grand mal à localiser l'armée ennemie
il décide alors de séparer ses troupes
en plusieurs points stratégiques
grave erreur car dans la nuit les
autrichiens qui ont l'avantagé du nombre
ont pris position en face des français
ils sont certains de l'emporter quand
l'armée de bonaparte et miraculeusement
sauvée par l'unité de reconnaissance du
général desaix qui entendent entonné les
canons sur l'arrière prend la décision
de désobéir au premier consul et
rebroussent chemin
la contre offensive française tourne là
presque des routes en victoires et vient
à bout des autrichiens marquant la fin
de la guerre
à présent la france contrôle un
territoire qui s'étend jusqu'à la rive
ouest du rhin au république d'italie et
des pays-bas
à partir de là il faut aussi réorganisé
toute la france qui est dans un piteux
état suite à la terreur et aux errements
du directoire la paix bien que de courte
durée permet au premier consul d'asseoir
sa légitimité de chef et de se tourner
vers les problèmes intérieurs alors
napoléon est un homme organisé dans sa
tête dans son dans sa personnalité si
bien qu'il ne veut pas être dirigé un
pays qui soit un petit peu en panique
alors il va créer il va créer des textes
de lois que ça dure leçon appelle le
code napoléon le code civil qui va
mettre au point régulariser tout la
situation des français
[Musique]
il prouve alors ses grandes qualités
d'administrateur
mais la guerre civile fait encore rage
dans certaines parties du pays en
particulier dans l'ouest
napoléon instaure par décret des
réformes qui rétablissent un ordre légal
et améliore la vie de la classe moyenne
il rédige un système de loi le code
napoléon qui regroupe les lois relatives
au droit civil français
il traite du droit des personnes de la
famille de la propriété de la
transmission des biens des contrats
imposés à toul empire ce code civil
inspiré le droit civil de nombreux états
napoléon promulgue aussi le code pénal
germaine de staël devenu farouche
opposante de napoléon bonaparte et
contrainte à l'exil en suisse où elle
publie son roman delphine elle y explore
les bouleversements sociaux de son temps
et constate à travers le code napoléon
la régression de la condition féminine
quant aux droits acquis pendant la
révolution mis sous tutelle au sein d'un
système patriarcal les femmes mettront
près d'un siècle à reconquérir leurs
droits
[Musique]
la signature du concordat reconnaît le
catholicisme comme la religion de la
majorité des français et assure la
liberté religieuse
bonaparte entame également des réformes
dans le domaine de l'éducation
il va créer les lycées en france le
lycée condorcet par exemple est une
création de bonaparte
c'est lui qui va créer également l'école
polytechnique qui va donner les grands
hommes que l'on connaît donc puisqu'elle
continue à exister de nos jours comme
cela quand c'est donc en fait c'est un
travail qui va dans toutes les
directions
il s'emploie à améliorer l'économie
fonds de la banque de france en 1800
pieds créé la cour des comptes et la
bourse de paris
la loi du 28 mars 1803 voit la création
d'une toute nouvelle monnaie le franc
germinal fixé en fonction de l'or et de
l'argent et qui conservera sa valeur
jusqu'en 1914
infatigable bâtisseur napoléon lance un
vaste programme de travaux la
construction de routes de canaux de porc
d'arc de triomphe à la gloire des
soldats de sa grande armée il aménage
paris perd cela rue de rivoli embellie
le jardin du luxembourg est le cimetière
du père lachaise créé le jardin des
plantes de nombreuses fontaines
le palais brongniart l'église de la
madeleine le canal de l'ourcq de saint
martin et de saint denis ou encore le
pont des arts
il va créer par exemple les préfets donc
il y avait déjà des préfigurations tout
le directoire
mais c'est lui qui va les instituts et
la personne du préfet devient agent de
la centralisation du pouvoir
nommé par le premier consul il veille à
l'ordre public à la rentrée des impôts
aux affaires économiques et au bon
déroulement de la conscription ce corps
préfectoral qui existent encore
pratiquement sous la même forme de nos
jours il est assisté d'un corps de sous
préfet c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas un
endroit du territoire qui ne soit pas
directement sous le contrôle d'un
administrateur délégué par le pouvoir
central
l'organisation des préfectures leur
action les résultats étaient admirables
et prodigieux la même impulsion se
trouvait donné au même instant à plus de
40 millions d'hommes et à l'aide de ces
centres d'activités locales
le mouvement était aussi rapide à toutes
les extrémités cocker même mémorial de
sainte-hélène jamais auparavant
l'administration n'avait connu un tel
prestige la légion d'honneur créer une
nouvelle aristocratie entièrement dévoué
à son chef les français ne sont pas
changés par dix ans de révolution est
donc un sentiment l'honneur il faut
donner un aliment à ce sentiment
il leur faut des distinctions napoléon
bonaparte
d'un côté l'assainissement financier de
l'autre l'administration ça va de paire
très centralisé de l'état c'est la
marque de bonaparte sur le premier
consulat
cette vague de projets le rétablissement
d'une autorité centrale crée les
conditions nécessaires à l'instauration
de la paix et de la stabilité
il est révéré comme le sauveur de la
france et de senna le déclare bientôt
premier consul à vie avec le droit de
choisir son successeur il devint alors
le maître absolu du pays
[Musique]
dans son ensemble la population est
heureuse de posséder enfin des lois
cohérente un traitement équitable et la
possibilité d'être récompensé pour son
excellence mais napoléon doit faire face
à une opposition des républicains et des
royalistes
après des années d'exil le frère de
louis saez maintien être louis xviii
souverain légitime de france il ya toute
la noblesse ancien qui est parti en exil
aussi qu'ils essayent de conspirer
régulièrement et il ya également
quelques officiers qui se méfient de
plus en plus et on ira jusqu'à connaître
même quelques conspiration le 24
décembre 1800 bonaparte échappe à
l'explosion d'une machine infernale au
passage de son carrosse
il exploite cet attentat font monter
contre lui pour justifier
l'établissement d'une nouvelle monarchie
héréditaire dont il prend la tête comme
empereur ainsi son futur fils héritera
t-il du trône ce qui rendra plus
difficile la restauration des bourbons
comme le notent les historiens on
assiste à l'une des plus grandes
ironie de l'histoire la france se tourne
vers un empereur pour protéger sa
révolution
[Musique]
le peuple français s'est soulevé pour
abolir la monarchie
comment napoléon peut-il être certain
que celui-ci approuvera sa décision d'en
créer une nouvelle
comme dans la plupart de ses tentatives
il prend un risque calculé
napoléon a consacré sa vie à forger son
image il est le républicain idéal
le patriote loyal le soldat invincible
le sauveur de la france et surtout ses
débuts modestes et son ascension
symbolise bien les objectifs de la
révolution alors napoléon d'hommes du
premier consul est encouragé ou
encouragent le sénat à faire en sorte
que le ce premier consul soit conçu la
vie et ensuite même empereur avec droits
de succession c'est à dire que s'il
avait un jour un héritier et bien cet
héritier deviendrait lui-même empereur
donc lempire héréditaire
il est couronné empereur sur la base de
ses propres mérites et selon la volonté
du peuple
en maître du faste et de la propagande
napoléon choisi des symboles comme
l'aigle qui le relie au grand empereur
du passé charlemagne césar les abeilles
rappelle les mérovingiens et la main de
la justice
les capétiens ainsi il porte la lignée
du bonaparte à la hauteur d'une
quatrième dynastie la création de l'
empire le 16 mai 10 804 c'est tout
simplement l'an une manière d'entériner
le consulat à vie en donnant un titre
très supérieur à bonaparte premier
consul tel qu'il l'avait été la suite au
coup d'état de brumaire voilà c'était
une récompense suprême si vous voulez de
la république
il ne faut jamais oublier que bonaparte
sur les papiers officiels signés
napoléon par la grâce de dieu et la
volonté des français donc qu'ils
manifestaient à la fois qu'il était
l'héritier des rois de france
comme il était l'héritier également de
la révolution française et de la
démocratie
la cérémonie de son couronnement à lui à
notre dame de paris le 2 décembre 1804
elle marque le début de l' empire
français et le règne de napoléon 1er
la présence du pape pie vii lui donne
une dimension supplémentaire et le place
au même niveau que le souverain du
saint-empire romain germanique
[Musique]
il se couronne lui-même puis couronne
son épouse l'impératrice joséphine
il ya des coalitions partout il ya
l'autriche à la prusse la russie
l'angleterre
il envisage déjà de faire ma base sur
l'angleterre c'est à dire de de
renouveler l'exploit qu'avait réussi
avant lui jules césar et guillaume le
conquérant menacés par l'expansion
française en europe la grande bretagne
est entraîné dans un nouveau conflit
bien décidés à régler les choses une
fois pour toutes à paul et au projet
d'attirer la flotte britannique hors de
la manche pour lancer une invasion sur
l'île
la marine française n'est pas sémillante
n'est pas encore très brillante alors
que la marine anglaise est vraiment de
très belle qualité et non seulement il
n'est pas sémillante mais toute cette
flotte commandé par l'amiral villeneuve
est au large de l'espagne et va subir
les foudres de l'amiral nelson à la
bataille de trafalgar
au cours des combats l'amiral nelson
détruit la majorité de la flotte franco
espagnole sans perdre un seul navire
il est mortellement blessé mais cette
victoire confirme la suprématie de la
flotte britannique
[Musique]
l'amiral villeneuve d'avoir toute la
flotte française
anéanti il va d'ailleurs rentrée et se
suicider parce qu'ils n'osaient pas se
présenter devant l'empereur
après cela napoléon ne tentera plus
jamais d'envahir l'angleterre
il cherchera à frapper la grande
bretagne de manière indirecte par la
conquête et la pacification de
l'ensemble de l'europe pour rester au
pouvoir
napoléon décide de dépasser les partis
politiques en se lançant dans une quête
de gloire nationale
sa grande armée compte 210 mille soldats
et ils espèrent avec l écrasé l'armée
autrichienne avant qu'elle ne reçoive
des renforts de la russie napoléon ne
m'ayant plus de flotte va faire demi
tour et a mené toute son armée contre
l'autriche la russie qu'il va rencontrer
à austerlitz précisément 1805 la
bataille des trois empereurs après une
avance rapide
napoléon exécute des manoeuvres
d'encerclement qui lui permet
d'emprisonner à hulme l'armée
autrichienne qui fait rapidement
reddition quand les russes rejoignent
les autrichiens près d'austerlitz
l'empereur montre son génie tactique en
mettant en place un piège élaboré à la
bataille d'austerlitz est absolument le
chef d'oeuvre de napoléon en quatre
heures il n'y a plus l'armée russe khl
l'armée russe commandé par le tsar en
personne compte soixante dix mille
hommes
napoléon est en infériorité numérique
mais en grand stratège il va exploiter
sa faiblesse en faisant croire à
l'ennemi qu'il a peur austerlitz et
enseigner non seulement à saint cyr en
france mais dans toutes les écoles
d'officiers du monde on apprend la
manoeuvre principal d'austerlitz qui
consista à choisir le terrain
il sacrifie délibérément ses positions
sur le plateau de prades scène pour
inciter les russes a attaqué à cet
endroit précis
malgré les mises en garde du général que
tout sauf alexandre tombent dans le
piège
le 2 décembre 1805 à l'aube le plateau
est noyée dans un épais brouillard
alexandre ordonne une attaque contre
l'ale droite française mais napoléon a
tout calculé
il a fait venir deux divisions de vienne
dans le plus grand secret menaçante
elles attendent les russes de pied ferme
en fête napoléon a été beaucoup plus
psychologue que véritablement militaire
dans cette bataille et c'est là sa
grande supériorité
napoléon a fait croire qu'il se cachait
pendant la nuit derrière des hauteurs de
manière à se cacher et pouvoir
disparaître pendant la nuit ce piège
dans lequel évidemment sont tombés les
russes et le lendemain matin napoléon a
réoccupé les auteurs et pousser les
russes dans des plats dans des étangs
gelés sur le côté ce qui fait qu'il ya
eu une canonnade très importante et il
ya eu beaucoup plus de morts russes
qu'ils n'auraient dû en avoir dans une
bataille rangée tout à fait
traditionnelle napoléon sans toi alors à
reprendre le plateau de prades scène
laissé pratiquement sans défense en
faisant avancer 17000 silhouette
dissimulé par le brouillard alexandre
comprendra bien trop tard son d'erreurs
le soleil qui va soulever le fameux
soleil d'austerlitz se lève un an jour
pour jour après le couronnement de
napoléon à notre dame de paris
considéré comme un chef-d'oeuvre de
stratégie militaire
la bataille d'austerlitz et la plus
grande victoire de napoléon 27 mille
soldats alliés y sont tués ou blessés
alors que les pertes françaises ne
s'élève qu'à 8000 âmes ça a été vraiment
un chef-d'oeuvre de psychologie
incontournable l'un des chocs de
l'histoire de la guerre de tous de tous
les temps la bataille ne met pas
seulement l'autriche hors d'état de
poursuivre la guerre elle contre un
empereur habsburg françois 2 abdiqué
c'est la fin officielle du saint-empire
romain germanique à la place napoléon
créé la configuration du rhin formé de
16 états allemands est dirigé selon le
modèle français
l'ex empereur conserve son titre de
françois 1er roi d'autriche
napoléon et déterminer maintenant à
étendre lempire jusqu'aux et allemands
situés à l'est du rhin dont la prusse
lorsqu'il ignore la demande de la prusse
de se retirer sur la rive ouest
elle se mobilise contre lui ainsi que la
russie napoléon réplique par une
compagnie clair ils attaquent les forces
prussienne à iéna pendant que le
maréchal davout se déplace vers à
hochstatt
[Musique]
les français remportent les deux
batailles poursuivant les restes de
l'armée prussienne en déroute
napoléon prend berlin et avance sur la
prusse orientale puis la pologne jusqu'à
la frontière russe
[Musique]
durant l'hiver 1807 napoléon établi ses
quartiers généraux à varsovie avant de
combattre les russes à hello menée sous
un climat atroce
la bataille se termine en une impasse
sanglante
napoléon a besoin d'une victoire pour
regagner le soutien de son peuple
c'est alors que le tsar alexandre 1er
propose une trêve
les russes étaient alliés des prussiens
qui avait été complètement écrasées par
l'armée française de napoléon et donc le
dard avait décidé de traiter une fois
pour toutes avec l'empereur la rencontre
entre napoléon et leuthard se conclut
dans une admiration mutuelle
ils finissent par négocier un traité qui
divise le continent entre les deux
puissances
et on fait des alliés contre les deux
ennemis que conserve l'empereur français
la grande-bretagne et la suède
napoléon rencontre le tsar de russie
ainsi que le roi et la reine de prusse
at-il site pour signer les deux traités
si la russie est traité en ami la prusse
et privés de la moitié de son territoire
la belle reine de prusse supplie
l'empereur français d'adoucir les dures
conditions qu'il impose à son pays mais
il refuse
alors de polo on va agrandir façon
fantastique le territoire français
puisque on va récupérer une grande
partie de l'italie on va récupérer les
pays bas etc
on va finir par avoir un nombre de
départements phénoménale et partout dans
toutes les régions et bien il place
certains de ses hommes la plupart du
temps ses frères d'ailleurs un joseph
bonaparte devient roi de naples et de
sicile et louis bonaparte roi de
hollande
les provinces prise à la prusse
deviennent des royaume gouverné par
jérôme bonaparte et joachim murat mari
de caroline bonaparte et lisa bonaparte
obtient de république italienne et le
grand duché de toscane
ça faisait dire à laetitia à la maman de
napoléon il dit
je ne connais pas de femmes au monde
puisque napoléon est empereur ses frères
sont rois ses soeurs sont duchesse de
l'ouest à la princesse etc
elle disait je ne connais pas de femmes
au monde qui ait donné autant de fessées
j'ai pu en donner moi allez roi à des
empereurs et à des princesses napoléon
1er est au sommet de sa puissance en
moins de trois ans l'autriche la prusse
et la russie ont été battus ce qui fait
de lui le maître de l'europe occidentale
et centrale
seule la grande-bretagne s'opposent
encore à sa domination
[Musique]
remuant ciel et terre napoléon déclare
une guerre économique contre la
grande-bretagne en décrétant un embargo
de grande envergure contre de commerce
britanniques l'ennemi de la france
traditionnelle depuis toujours c'est
l'angleterre s'était elle grâce à son
argent qui arrosait toute l'europe et
qui s'enrichissaient sur le dos de tous
les états d'europe
napoléon donc faire ch est tout
simplement à des tâches et l'europe de
l'angleterre
ce à quoi il avait réussi grâce au
traité tilsit avec les russes le blocus
continental rend toute importation de
marchandises britannique illégal
bonaparte fédé des guerres qui avait
l'air comme ça quand on les regarde
aujourd'hui à des horaires complètement
inutile pourquoi lé faire la guerre au
portugal va tout simplement c'était pour
éviter que le portugal le fasse du
commerce avec l'angleterre donc il
fallait bloquer toute communication
commerciale entre l'angleterre et le
reste du continent européen
[Musique]
mais en occupant le portugal l'empereur
se rend compte de l'instabilité de la
monarchie en place
il trompe les espagnols et mais joseph
bonaparte sur le trône
le traitement réservé aux bourbons
d'espagne et veille un sentiment de
crainte chez les habsbourgs très vite
l'autriche rond le traité qui l'a lié à
la france et rejoint l'angleterre dans
une autre coalition
napoléon est prise au dépourvu il
rassemble ses troupes et remporte
plusieurs batailles au début de la
campagne
mais lors de la bataille d'aspe renée
sling il frôle la défaite inférieure en
nombre et désavantages et
stratégiquement il est forcé de battre
en retraite
[Musique]
napoléon a perdu trop d'hommes il doit
remporter rapidement une victoire il va
l'obtenir à wagram le traité qui suit
est le plus rude que la france ait
jamais imposé à l'autriche
ce succès est l'un des plus
impressionnants qu'il est connu mais le
vent est sur le point de tourner
l'ennemi a appris à mieux se battre
plus de dix mille hommes périssent
pendant la courte guerre de 1809
c'est un nouveau record macabre le
peuple espagnol se soulève contre
l'occupation française et la grande
bretagne sous le commandement de
wellington va combattre à ses côtés
napoléon admettra plus tard que
l'aventuré espagnole était une grave
erreur
la guerre va traîner pendant des années
et coûter très cher et otéra la france
nombre de ses soldats et de ses
maréchaux l'église catholique refusent
de soutenir le système continental alors
napoléon va courir le risque de
récupérer les territoires du pape
bon eh bien ils les récupèrent et
territoires du pape mais le pape pie vii
lui lance callas dit eh bien puisque
c'est comme ça je vous excommunie
l'empereur le fait enlever et il ne
retiendra prisonnier pendant des années
la france renforce l'embargo et pourtant
la grande bretagne reste ferme
pire encore la mauvaise gestion de ses
victoires par napoléon son comportement
tyrannique envers les autres peuples
ainsi qu'à l'égard du pape unis toute
l'europe contre lui
[Musique]
se sentant menacé il ressent le besoin
impératif d'avoir un héritier
il a déjà adopté le fils et la fille de
joséphine
mais cette dernière n'a pu lui donner un
enfant napoléon est très attaché à elle
met sa vie amoureuse a cessé depuis bien
longtemps d'être pour lui une priorité
[Musique]
alors le sénat a donc rédigé ce texte en
disant que l' empire pouvait être était
même héréditaire et oui mais le problème
qui se pose c'est que napoléon
bien que marié avec joséphine n'a pas
d'héritier et il s'aperçoit très
rapidement il a cru son médecin
corvisart lui disait qu'il était stérile
bon mais il s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas
lui qui est stérile parce que il a eu
une aventure avec une lectrice de sa
soeur caroline qui s'appelle eléonore de
noël de laplaigne et il lui a fait un
enfant un enfant d'ailleurs la belle et
les honneurs lui dit on va l'appeler
napoléon lui dit non léon suffira et à
partir de ce moment-là il sait qu'il
n'est pas stérile donc joséphine est
condamné
il annuler son mariage et négocier une
alliance avec la fille du roi d'autriche
l'archiduchesse marie louise
[Musique]
il construira un arc de triomphe pour
célébrer l'événement et quelques mois
plus tard la nouvelle impératrice
attendra un enfant au premier coup de
canon annonçant la délivrance de
l'impératrice tout paris restait en
suspens dans les promenades dans les
rues dans l'intérieur des maisons dans
les assemblées publiques la population
toute entière fut occupé à compter le
nombre de coups de canon le 22e excite a
livré général il était d'usagé de tir et
21 coups de canons pour la naissance
d'une princesse et sans un coup pour
celle d'un prince mémorial de
sainte-hélène la naissance de son fils
apaise napoléon il sait qu'il est
maintenant lié à l'un des plus vieux
empire d'europe à la dynastie des
habsbourg ce qui légitime son empire
tout récent c'est héritiers assure
également la pérennité de ce qu'il a
construit
la france contrôle maintenant l'europe
de l'espagne à la pologne
les historiens pensent que c'est à cette
époque que napoléon alors âgé de 40 ans
forment un grand projet d'union
politique européenne avec paris pour
capitale la russie impériale et tenta
liée à l' empire français
rien ne s'oppose à ce qu'il puisse
remodelé l'europe et en faire une
communauté transcontinental mais il
n'avait pas prévu que le tsar
commencerait à s'irriter des termes du
traité
[Musique]
tout cela va créer des problèmes
également entre l'e commerce réciproque
russes et français qui vont de plus en
plus aller de mal en pis et finalement
tout cela va mener à la campagne de
russie
le mariage d'alliance de napoléon avec
l'autriche inquiète alexandre 1er de
russie mais la situation en pologne est
encore plus préoccupante la pole et on a
un excellent et territoires polonais cd
par la prusse et la russie n'apprécie
pas que les troupes françaises soit si
proche de sa frontière
pas plus que l'établissement d'une
noblesse féodale en pologne et
l'instauration de réformes semblable à
celle qui l'a mise en place en france
la russie souffre aussi du système
continental de napoléon alexandre 1er
soumis à une forte pression intérieure
reprend les échanges commerciaux avec la
grande bretagne son retrait du système
continental marque la fin des bonnes
relations entre les deux dirigeants
la guerre économique menée par napoléon
s'avère être une épée à double tranchant
certes l'économie britannique en souffre
beaucoup
mais la france et ses alliés tout autant
voire davantage en 1811 les pays sous
son contrôle croule sous les dettes
une génération entière de français a été
décimée par la guerre la france suffoque
toute la jeunesse s'enthousiasmait pour
les victoires les bulletins de la grande
armée qui annonçait sans cesse les
victoires napoléoniennes
malheureusement à la longue évidemment
les campagnes commençait un peu à se
vider on estime qu'il ya eu environ un
million cinq cent mille morts depuis la
guerre commencée en 1792 au début de la
révolution donc jusqu'en 1840 de ski à
waterloo
donc effectivement autour de 1810 déjà
on voit apparaître des réfractaires si
vous voulez des soldats qui refusent de
partir de laisser leurs familles et qui
pour beaucoup ce couple d'oies ou ceux
où ce couple et tendons du doigt de
façon à ne pas pouvoir tirer au fusil
certains également s'arrachent les dents
de ne fasse de façon à ne pas pouvoir
déchirer les cartouches qui était en
papier et à partir desquels donc on vide
elle la poudre noire dans le
dans les lumières des fusils devant
l'impossibilité de mettre la grande
bretagne genoux des ministres de
napoléon recherche désespérément la paix
mais l'empereur ne peut plus s'arrêter
au lieu de retirer ses troupes d'europe
centrale et orientale de consolider ses
positions de façon réaliste et
d'admettre l'échec évident de ces plans
économique militaire et géopolitique
il persiste dans sa quête de domination
mondiale
[Musique]
l' empire de napoléon s'effiloche dans
notre prochain épisode
nous explorerons les dernières campagnes
militaires de l'empereur il ya des
milliers de morts des milliers de morts
et il va falloir des deux ou trois ou
quatre voire quatre générations avant
que la france ne se sortent cette
saignée nous verrons comment la
brutalité des guerres successives et
l'invasion de la russie anéantiront une
génération entière d'hommes et comment
paris tombera aux mains de l'ennemi
pendant que talleyrand discutera avec
alexandre 1er de la restauration des
bourbons
on a attribué à la fortune mais plus
grand acte et on ne manquera pas
d'imputer les revers mais faute mais si
j'écris mes campagnes on sera bien
étonné de voir que dans les deux cas est
toujours à raison et mes facultés
s'exerçait rck en conformité avec les
principes mémorial de sainte-hélène
les vainqueurs exigeront l'empereur sur
l'île d'elbe installant louis xviii sur
le trône de france pendant que la
population célébrera la paix enfin
retrouvé napoléon attendra son heure il
s'échappera de sa prison insulaires pour
s'engager dans ce qui reste le plus
grand come back de tous les temps à
chaque fois que l'empereur apparaît tout
le monde se rallie une fois encore à lui
parce que c'est le personnage le plus
légendaire qui soit mais son bref retour
au pouvoir
durera seulement son jour et s'achèvera
avec la terrible défaite de waterloo
avant de partir pour un dernier exil à
sainte hélène
[Musique]
napoléon bonaparte s'est imposé comme le
digne successeur de césar sans autre
atout que son intelligence son génie son
inflexible volonté et son indomptable
énergie il est devenu l'empereur des
français
son ambition sans borne l'a conduit à
conquérir l'europe et a mené son pays au
sommet d'une gloire sans précédent mais
lorsque son génie et son ego sont
devenus incontrôlables
la france s'est retrouvée un genou on a
commencé à qualifier l'empereur d'ogre
de dévoreur de jeunes vies de dévoreur
de soldats donc les caricatures ou couru
sur ce thème
l'échec de napoléon ne réside pas dans
son désir de conquête mais dans le fait
qu'il était incapable de s'arrêter tant
qu'il n'était pas vainqueur il se
défendra ainsi d'avoir un caractère
belliqueux dans son mémorial de
sainte-hélène
on le sait ce de parler de mon amour
pour la guerre mais n'ai-je pas été
constamment occupée à me défendre
elle remporté une seule victoire que je
n'ai immédiatement proposé la paix je
n'ai jamais été véritablement mon maître
mais j'ai toujours été gouverné par les
circonstances
il n'en reste pas moins que son nom
inspire aura toujours les froids et
l'histoire le jugera pour avoir confondu
son destin avec celui de la france